yasa tell him he's closing his doors
early today as he's forced to do one day
every May when Israeli marches make his
street unsafe
they want this to
prove that the Joseph told them
and in a way they want to educate people
and prove that they are the leaders of
this city and they are the ruler of the
city
yasa's owned this clothing shop for
decades Jerusalem's Old City the only
home his family has ever known this is
born here I'm born in the orchidia in
part of New York City my spirit is in
All City
but this afternoon he's avoiding the
so-called flag March an annual event
that overruns this part of town
[Applause]
with Israeli nationalists walking
through the streets while Lee waving
flags
[Music]
the mostly young Marchers are both
pushed and yet protected by Israeli
police
seeking to prove their power over
Palestinians with chance and taunts
foreign
possible thanks to this police presence
is Michael panzak from Brooklyn New York
there's plenty of security around I
don't think uh I think during a typical
day around here is not so safe for Jews
to walk around
for Israelis I mean if you're a pair
like a drill now there's a lot of
security you could see over here
an anti-arab group's Flags visible in
Black protesters telling us their
behavior is now backed by the government
some marches from this once Fringe
movement are now major players in
Israel's coalition
none more so than idmah bengavir the
minister for National Security welcomed
as a hero outside the city's Damascus
gate
his divisive rise to prominence
important perhaps of more trouble to
come
occupied East Jerusalem